what
smoking back everyone so part two like
part one is going to be about methods
for articulating structure and data
articulating which inputs you view the
most relevant the difference is in part
one we looked at really deterministic
conditions so these stability notions
for clustering and the r.i.p condition
for compressive sensing whereas in part
two we're going to be looking entirely
at models that are probabilistic in some
sense so we're going to be using
distributions over inputs in all of
these models so let me start with a sort
of two technical topics and then to kind
of just lightweight topics at the end so
the first main thing I want to talk
about are planted models and semi-random
models so let's begin with what's now a
very famous problem the planet clique
problem there's a long time where planet
cleek was like a pretty obscure corner
of the universe but we've heard a lot
about it over the last five years it's
kind of gone viral so what's the plan of
kalique problem and you know so the idea
is you know what would be you know in
the spirit of having meaningful
clusterings you know could we have a
distribution over cleek instances where
sort of there's a meaningful maximum
clique defined so you start with just
you know your basic random graph
erdos-renyi edge density one half so
that's this thing here then you plan a
clique in it meaning for some parameter
K you choose K vertices at random and
you just connect all of them to each
other so you add the clink ok and then
the algorithm is given this as input and
of course the algorithm is supposed to
recover the clique in polynomial time so
this problem is only going to get easier
as we take K bigger and bigger right the
bigger the planted click the easier you
going to be able to find it so you can
ask questions like ok so how big do we
have to take K before the clique problem
becomes polynomial-time solvable ok so
what's the state of the art so the state
of the art by ilan privilege and pseudo
cough shows that well if the klique is
at least a constant times root in and
here's the number of vertices then there
is a polynomial time algorithm that
finds it ok so that's an old positive
result these days we're hearing a lot
more about the planet click hardness
conjecture which is the conjecture that
actually no polynomial time algorithm
can recover clicks that are
asymptotically smaller than this
so we don't know whether that's true or
not it's just sort of a hardness
assumption one can put forth and more
and more now people are designing or
using the planning clear coordinates
assumptions to prove hardness for other
types of problems and also you know
lately we've been seeing some really
nice unconditional lower bounds for
restricted models of computation like
sums of squares or like statistical
query algorithms but I don't wanna talk
about any of that stuff okay this is a
talk about algorithms about upper bounds
I want to talk about lower bounds and
hardness so instead i want to say okay
let's look at the algorithms for
recovering planted clicks are they
interesting well the alona tal algorithm
is interesting actually but what I want
to commit you on the next slide is that
if we're happy with just a tiny bit
weaker guarantee we could get it with an
algorithm which is definitely not
interesting okay so let's say actually I
made the klique a little bit bigger so i
made the problem a little bit easier so
square root of quantity and log in
that's something the cleats going to be
I claim then it's it's you can recover
in polynomial time anyone have a guess
what the what the algorithm might be
it's not a very interesting algorithm
good just look at the degrees okay so
let me explain so imagine what the graph
looks like just when you have the odish
renea graph and you haven't planted the
klique yet okay density is one-half
remember so what's the degree of a
vertex well you know it's basically
looks like a Gaussian with mean and over
two and you know it's going to peter out
you know at plus minus square root login
standard deviations standard deviation
is rooted so this is what the degree
distribution looks like before you plant
the klique now suppose you plan a clique
of size at least you know some constant
times square root n log n that means if
you're one of yous cleat if your wording
the vertices that was selected to be in
the klique even if your degree before
the planting was all the way over here
the klique will catapult you all the way
to the right hand side of the bell curve
okay so all of the cleat vertices are
going to be to the right of the bell
curve so you can just recover them by
returning the top k the vertices are the
top k degrees ok so and this is not very
i claim this is not an interesting
algorithm in the sense that if you tried
to run it on real networks you know you
get back the top k max degree vertices
and they wouldn't be a clique
and you would have missed out on the
real click okay so this is not something
which is going to generalize from this
planet click model to other models of
networks and the way I would describe
this is somehow like impugn specific
input distribution it unfortunately kind
of naturally led us to this algorithm
which is sort of brittle and really kind
of an artifact of the specific
distribution that we assume and in
general we're going to aspire toward
results that are much more robust than
that actually just a quick step back so
so Jay mentioned average case analysis
in part one so yeah like that planet
cleats flat is pretty much the only
slide of the talk that's on sort of you
know basic average case analysis by
which I mean you really posit
distribution over inputs and just
optimize say expected algorithm
performance over that input okay so
that's classical average case analysis
it's not to say this is not useful okay
there are definitely situations where
average case analysis is exactly what
you want to do so you know if you have a
problem you have a very detailed
understanding of the input distribution
and it's relatively stable over time and
you don't actually need a general
purpose solution to the problem you just
need to solve your one specific
application and increasingly like in Big
Data companies actually all of these
assumptions are met so you know these
really are real problems so if you
satisfy all of those things then by all
means you know use the algorithm with
the best performance with respect to the
one distribution which you have good
confidence in you know but of course you
know if you're a little uncertain about
the distribution or it's changing
rapidly you know or you want to have
sort of more robust algorithms then you
really need to go beyond this so that's
the theme of part two what would be
robust versions of average case analysis
all right so let me show you the first
version which is going to be the idea of
semi-random models so the phrase
semi-random actually comes from pseudo
randomness in the 80s a paper of Santa
and umesh vazirani but the idea of
applying the to a comet oriole problems
was due to Blum and Blum and Spencer and
so they were looking at graph coloring
problems and the idea in a semi-random
model is in addition to nature I in
addition to an input distribution you're
going to have an adversary and nature in
the adversary will collaborate to
produce an input which is then fed to an
algorithm and as many ways you can
define these models will see several so
I'm going to look at the fog achillion
semi-random model
for planted click where nature goes
first and what nature does is exactly
the same as before so it nature again
pics the irda strand your graph and
plants are random click then the
adversary gets to go second and modify
the graph okay now if you think about it
we need to restrict the adversary right
otherwise the adversary you could just
delete the original graph and replace it
with a hard instance so we're going to
look at a monotone adversary which is an
adversary that can only affect the
instance in a way that's intuitively
helpful that should make it easier to
solve so for the klique problem that
means you know the cliq itself it should
leave alone and the other stuff the
ambient stuff the adversary wants it can
make its parser it can delete edges that
are outside the clique if it wants
intuitively this should just make the
click more pronounced and easier to
recover but if you think about it that's
stupid algorithm from the planet models
not going to work if you just take the
top K degrees in general you will not
recover this planted click the adversary
can just delete lots of edges in between
the click and the rest of the graph
lowering the degrees of the cleat
vertices and that algorithm is going to
miss them so it breaks that algorithm
which is good so it does it encourage us
to design more robust algorithms for
click finding it seems to so the
state-of-the-art here the threshold on k
is it actually exactly the same as in
the planted model safaga and craft gamer
gave a polynomial time algorithm that
recovers the click even in the semi
random model again for K down to omega
root n their algorithm you know is
something that you know you might
plausibly want to use or at least build
on which is a suitable SDP relaxation
for the problem based on the on a low
wash data function okay so that's the
state of the art for random and
semi-random planted click I want to talk
about one other semi-random model for
kilometro problem because this is
somewhere it both has a rich history and
it's been some exciting developments
just in the past few months which I want
to tell you about so here it's going to
be planted by section so this is a
special case of what's called the
stochastic block model these days some
people are calling this community
detection although if I'm honest I think
it's a little bit of a stretch to call
it that it is related but i like to call
it planted by section so you have two
groups of n over two vertices the
bisection that you're planning is the by
section of the graph into a and
be okay and you want this bisection to
be cheap meaning that fewer edges cross
this cut better than any other by
section so in the random models again
this is not the semi-random model is
just the random model you're going to
fill in the two groups with a relatively
large edge density p and then you're
going to fill in the edges in between a
and B with a relatively small edge
density q so accusing to be less than P
here okay so each edge here is there
independently with probability P each
edge here is there independently with
probability Q and here intuitively the
bigger the gap is between P&Q the more
obvious will be this planted by section
the more obvious will be this grouping
of the graph into a and B so what people
have thought a lot about and actually
there's this and you know pretty deep
and kind of amazing work on this is for
exactly which values of P and Q so for
how big a gap can you recover this
planted by section in polynomial time
and there are very precise answers known
to this question and you even have
exhibit you even have things in the semi
random model so what would be the
semi-natural monotone adversary for
bisection well again you should make the
problem only easier the adversary so
it's allowed to add edges within each of
the two groups or it's allowed to delete
edges between the two groups so that's
the semi-random model of planet by
section and the results for the random
model generally extend to the
semi-random model actually so this is
kind of like the limits of my animation
ability so let's just like watch that a
couple times before the adversary after
the adversary before after so the the
state of the art for the for the planet
by section was basically the same random
or semi-random you had to work harder in
the semi random model I can plan a Kleek
but now actually for a variant of the
model we have the first separation
really showing that semi-random models
or its strict a strictly harder problem
so for this we need to look at the
sparse regime so again remember p is the
edge density inside the groups q is in
between the groups we're going to both
of these is being really small ok so
like constant over n basically gonna be
different constants and a here will be
bigger than because P needs to be bigger
than Q and you think about this for a
second you realize you're not going to
cover a and B no way this these edge
densities are so low that in the air
dinner erdos-renyi graph with these
kinds of densities you don't even have a
connected graph you have isolated nodes
you have a giant component but you have
a bunch of isolated nodes how do you
know if an isolated notes supposed to be
an a or in B you have no clue okay you
have no information at all so you can
still hope to do partial recovery though
you'd like to at least classify the
vertices into a and B better than random
guessing so again you can ask the
question for what values of P and Q can
this be done or not be done beat random
guessing as far as you know classifying
into a and B so again in the in the
random model in a sequence of you know
again you know pretty deep results just
a few years ago this question has been
totally nailed and it's kind of an
amazing criterion so remember a and B or
the coefficients and edge densities and
so we expect that the bigger the gap is
the bigger a minus B the more possible
it should be to do partial recovery and
in fact if and only if a minus B
quantity squared is bigger than two
times a plus B in that case you can do
partial recovery even efficiently if
you're not if you're defect condition is
not satisfied you cannot do partial
recovery even information theoretically
okay so you kind of completely nailed
down the rent the regime the the
parameters in which you can do this
that's where the random model so what
about for the semi-random model there's
defined just like before so an adversary
can delete edges crossing the bisection
or add edges inside each of the two
clusters and so this was just in stock a
couple months ago Mort riparian wine
they show there's actually a separation
they show that in the sparse regime
there exists a monotone adversary that
can actually screw up every algorithm
even in parameter regimes where this
condition holds okay so there exists an
infinite set of choices for a and B so
that this condition holds and hence
partial recovery is possible in the
random model but it is not possible in
the semi random model there is a
monotone adversary that can screw up all
of the algorithms the gap is the gap
isn't huge so if you replace this with a
larger constant all of a sudden you can
get semi-random algorithms for recovery
but the shows that really is a
difference but between the two models
so there's still nice open questions i
think around semi-random models i think
there's still a lot to do so you know
one thing that's sort of you can't help
but notice is for all of the positive
results for these semi-random models it
seems to always be a semi definite
programming relaxation which kind of
gives you what you want and there's a
question of is there some generic sense
in which SDP relaxations are the best
robust algorithms the best algorithms
for semi-random models there's some
suggestive results along these lines in
the motor at all paper that I mentioned
you know you can imagine trying to
weaken the assumptions about nature and
or about the adversary all right so
maybe then maybe nature doesn't do
independent edge probabilities maybe the
adversary can at least have some
violations of monotonicity that's
important you know having a weaker
models and positive results there's some
nice results again by McCarthy from
Cardiff and vijayaraghavan these are
different papers than the multi wake up
when I mentioned before those are for
graph partitioning problems and what
else so the motor oil separation which
in the random and the semi-random cases
that's information theoretic you could
imagine cases where you'd see a
computational separation between the two
regimes where information theoretically
you can recover up to a certain
threshold in both the random and the
semi-random cases but you can only get
it to be computationally efficient in
the random case at least based on some
average case assumptions and then
finally you know like i said it's sort
of a cottage industry now to prove you
know conjectured average case hardness
or worst case hardness for problems you
know using planted click it's only a
weaker assumption to assume that it's
hard to do semi-random plan to cle right
it's a harder problem so it's a weaker
hardness assumption so you know how many
of the implications of planning click
hardness extend under the week or
semi-random hardness assumptions another
thing I'm curious about well I'm on the
topic of open questions you know I can't
help but briefly plug a recent paper I
wrote with glow verson sonntag and yield
room so this disappeared in a machine
learning conference because this
connections to structured prediction so
I don't again I think this sort of flew
under the radar of the algorithms
community but there's some really juicy
open questions here I think people in
this room and then the algorithm unity
would really like so let me just show
you what those open questions are so
what's the model so again there's going
to be some unknown objects implanted
object that we want to recover at least
partially so
what you do know upfront is you know a
graph okay maybe like the grid maybe
you're looking at an image and each
pixel correspond via cortex what you
don't know is an unknown binary labeling
of the vertices of this graph so that's
the red and the blue of the different
vertices so imagine I gave you the graph
and I wanted you I didn't give you the
colors and I want you to tell me what
the colors were all right so what
information do I give you to try to make
inference about who's colored what well
suppose i give you the parody of each
edge okay so like this edge it has
different endpoints so the parody would
be one this edge has the same color end
point so it's parody would be zero you
know 0 1 1 1 etc suppose they give you a
parody for every edge actually not quite
so that would actually be easier if you
think about a little bit you can just
immediately recover up to a permutation
of written red and blue the unknown
labeling so it's interesting when the
parodies are noisy ok so I'll give you
what I gave you before except with some
probability P each edge gets flipped ok
so maybe you get a 0 here if it's if
it's a noisy edge maybe you get a 1 here
if it's a noisy edge ok so that's the
model the noise can be random or
semi-random it doesn't matter for our
results and the goal is to recover X to
figure out which nodes are red which
nodes are blue actually one thing again
sort of like in that sparse regime for
planted by section you realize
immediately that if the graph is too
sparse you're not going to be able to
figure out all of X right so like an a
bounded degree graph like the grid you
know some of these vertices will just
have all corrupted edges around it and
you're gonna have no way of figuring out
where that vertex belongs ok so at least
in general we're thinking about
approximate recovery where the
classification error the number of nodes
the fraction of those that you get wrong
should be going to 0 as the noise goes
to 0 again when the noise actually is 0
we know you can do recovery and you'd
like to say that with small noise you
can recover almost as well as in the
full information case so what we proved
is we basically show you can do this in
some graphs and you can't do it and some
other graphs so for example you know if
the graphs an expander we can show that
you can always approximately recover the
unknown binary labeling that's not
computationally efficient unfortunately
our algorithm
on the other hand for planar graph
specifically bounded face planar graphs
including the grid which is what we were
motivated by you can do approximate
recovery and even computationally
efficiently okay so as the noise goes to
zero there exists an algorithm you can
polynomial time for the grid case so
that the classification error goes to 0
with the noise under these are not
trivial results and in particular you
have to use the graph structure when you
prove these results because some graphs
is just false if I give you a path graph
actually even as I take the noise 20
every algorithm is going to have
classification error remained it bounded
away from zero then always the error
does not go away in the limit as you as
you take P 20 ok so those are sort of
the highlights of our results we have
some cases where we know how to figure
out what X is we have some cases where
we can prove you can and there's so much
stuff we don't understand it's a little
embarrassing actually so I love to have
a characterization or at least a week or
sufficient condition on the graph
structure which is sufficient to get
approximate recovery of this unknown
labeling it seems like some you know
expansion is too strong right the grid
isn't an expander but we can still do it
but maybe some week or analog of
expansion is what sort of driving these
results you know this case is where we
need polynomial time algorithms and we
don't have them a natural way to modify
the model is to get noise not signals
not just from the edges but also from
the nodes so maybe for each node i tell
you red or blue and three out of four
times it's right 104 times it's wrong
for a node we have no algorithms which
take advantage of extra noisy of
additional noisy node labels and finally
you know so two labels is great if
you're just trying to like segment an
image into the foreground in the
background but usually an image
segmentation you kind of have more than
one regions you want a segment stuff
into that would correspond to a labeling
which is not binary which has you know
more than just two possible colors we
have literally no results even for three
colors we don't even know where to get
started okay so lots of opportunities
here I think okay really solving linear
equations with the arrows in because
it's like
equations that I am here to only pairs
but the hardness resulting programa para
news yet for pearl learning learning
noisy parodies you're saying solving
linear equations with I mean this is
what he revealed sure yeah there's no
formal connection known I mean I see the
analogy but there's no reductions known
between the problems
if it's partly for a change everything
many games right it's my Z let's late to
the club fine okay so what so claim is
this is a special case of other known
hard problems or ok so you deducted well
I also want to point out you're talking
all about computationally efficient
results I'm also interested just in
information theoretically like when
actually can you recover this labeling
and when can you not in the spirit of
the results we talked about in the
planet models so I agree for the
computational results when you're in the
regime where it is information
theoretically possible maybe that's the
right avenue for actually proving
hardness that you're not going to get
computation results matching the
information theoretic ones but even the
information theoretic side we really
don't know what's the meaning of the
baggage no no no sorry about a number of
edges / face so in it the dual graph
should be bounded degree yeah thanks
yeah you have faced transitions over
here like for the previous city where
you have like this position where
recovery is possible and as soon as the
Arrow Cross said it's not possible so
here it seems like it's smooth that's
right that's right
in part because you know our objective
function here isn't binary I mean you
could imagine you know you could imagine
and maybe people have done this but you
could imagine looking at partial
recovery and graph by section and
talking about what fraction of the nodes
you get back correctly as a function of
the parameter values so that would be
the analog of the kind of question we're
asking here give it an absolute pressure
gauges are flipped what it can do is
that we can recover some labelings we
should satisfy the one minus root the
absolute fraction of the labels but i
don't but i don't know whether I think
it's more that it satisfies 1 minus root
up some fraction of the constraints yeah
so but that's not our objective function
right and this is this is a difference
from the CSP formulations of this we
don't we don't care about how many you
know of these things right so we know
they're noisy so we don't really don't
care how many you conform to we care
about how many vertices you got right so
the technical work here is largely
saying okay well what if we do some
optimization based on the edges under
what conditions can we translate that to
a bound on the nodes that that is sort
of the nature of these proofs
so now that the path is a disaster the
path you basically just lose too much
information just you know you'll have a
couple edges get flipped and it's
because there's sort of you know only
one path in between any two vertices you
just completely lose any information
about how things are correlated with
each other so the lower back for the
paths information theoretic it's not
about algorithms it's just you don't
have enough information to do it alright
so that's the that's the first main
topic I want to do is sort of one other
technical topic I wanted to cover and
then we'll have two short topics at the
end so next is going to be smooth
analysis so this is another type of a
semi-random model where nature in the
adversary can collaborate and so the
specific semi-random model was proposed
by Spielman and tang the order in which
the two players go is reversed so here
the adversary is going to go first and
for some computational problem that you
fixed the adversary will pick some input
think of it as like a hard input of this
computational problem then nature is
going to add a small perturbation to
this input chosen by the adversary so we
just flicks it a little bit intuitively
and what do you want you want an
algorithm which no matter what the
adversary does the algorithm should do
well on average on average over nature's
perturbation okay that's the goal and
still kind of the biggest killer
application of smooth analysis is
arguably the original one by Spielman
and tang so they were thinking about
linear programming and specifically they
were thinking about the simplex method
and the running time in a smooth sense
of the simplex method and let me tell
you about the the perturbation model for
linear programs right so linear program
specified by the objective function the
constraint matrix on the right hand side
so they proposed that an independent
small Gaussian gets added to each entry
of the constraint matrix in each entry
of the right hand side okay and small
here that's that's controlled by say the
standard deviation of this Gaussian
which is what i'm using denoting by feet
okay so that's the model and they show
that in this model no matter what linear
program you start with on average over
this perturbation the expected running
time of the simplex method at least if
you use you know this one pivot rule the
shadow pivot rule is polynomial so what
is polynomial smooth complexity mean
what means first of all it should be
polynomial time in the input size like
usual you're also allowed paloma
dependence on one over the size of
nature's perturbations and if you think
about it some dependence here is clearly
needed right so as the perturbation goes
to 0 we know that the running time of
the simplex method blows up to
exponential so it needs to be for
sufficiently big perturbations so what
this is sort of saying is as long as the
perturbations are at least inverse
polynomial then this will run in
polynomial time okay so that's so that's
the result for the simplex method I'm
not going to say really anything more
about this you know both because i think
this this result is well known and i
want to focus on some less while no
one's also it's a quite technical result
so it's kind of hard to peek under the
hood in limited time so the next thing I
want to mention is a really nice result
of bear and walking in the context of
binary optimization problem so let me
tell you what the goal what are they
trying to do they're trying to
understeer man and tang they used smooth
smooth analysis to analyze a specific
algorithm they were motivated by the
specific case of the simplex method and
they wanted to know what was its
performance Byron Bocking are motivated
more by problems than by algorithms so
they're asking the question for which
problems does there exist some algorithm
that has polynomial smooth complexity
and they wanted to understand which
problems have polynomial smooth
complexity and which ones do not ok so
Spielman and tank sort of took the
algorithm is fixed up front Byron
bocking are happy to design a new
algorithm to certify that you're smooth
polynomial-time solvable ok so what is a
binary optimization problem so this is
the family of problems in which they get
a very clean characterization so maybe
think of knapsack as the canonical
binary optimization problem so in
general you have in binary decision
variables like whether to put an item in
the knapsack or not let's assume that
the objective is to maximize the total
value subject to feasibility constraints
and the perturbation is going to be here
in the coefficients of the objective
function ok so the VIS again you can
think of it sort of lying randomly in
some interval of at least inverse poly
length and then the other thing you need
to specify us what are the constraints
and as you vary the constraints you get
different problems with wildly different
complexities ok so obviously knapsack is
one that just says the feasible sets are
the collections of items whose weight
through at most the knapsack capacity
you
polynomial-time solvable algorithms like
maximum spanning tree or you could have
like super hard problems like max weight
independent set those are all special
cases of binary optimization problems
just depending on how you set the
constraints so Byron Bocking given if
and only if characterization for which
binary optimization problems have
polynomial smooth complexity ie admit an
algorithm with smooth polynomial running
time what is the characterization a
binary optimization problem is in smooth
polynomial time if and only if it can be
solved in pseudo polynomial time so for
example if you have a weakly np-hard
problem like the knapsack problem it
actually becomes easy once you path to
the smooth model it solve in polynomial
time smooth polynomial time you have a
strongly np-hard problem it does not
become easy it remains hard even in the
smooth model okay so that's the result
if and only if so let me say a little
bit about the proof this will be the one
thing I see a little bit up about the
proof in part two in particular because
there's a nice connection to a frame
famous resort called the isolation lemma
so I'm only gonna talk about the up
direction the only if Direction is easy
that would just say you know if I
promise you that you can solve something
quickly under perturbations then you
could solve it in pseudo polynomial time
and that you just proved by taking a
suitably small random perturbation so
what about if so the hard part is to say
suppose the only thing you know about
this binary optimization problem is that
I give you a black box that solves it
optimally in pseudo polynomial time that
is all you know and you have to prove
that there's perhaps some other
algorithm which runs in the smooth sense
in polynomial time for randomly
perturbed vis again think of the VIS is
you know lying say uniformly in some
interval of inverse polynomial length so
think of this is polynomial okay all
right so the way this is done is through
the isolation lemma this was originally
proved by normally vazirani and boss
Ronnie in the context of parallel
computation but it has lots of
applications across the computer science
now let me tell you what the original
version of the isolation limo was they
were thinking about matchings but the
proof works for any binary optimization
problem and they said suppose you have
and unweighted graph and now suppose you
independently assign a random integer to
each edge of the graph say between 1 and
N squared or something like that ok then
with high probability there will be only
one there will be a unique maximum
weight matching there will not be two
different matchings that are both
maximum ok that's the isolation limit
with high probability over the choice of
the integers for the edges there's a
unique maximum matching or the way I
want you to think about this by saying
it's a unique maximum matching they're
saying that the gap between the best
matching and the second best matching is
at least one diagonal lower bound on the
gap between the first best and the
second vest so in the present context
we're not dealing with random integers
we're dealing with these perturbed vis
but that just kind of scales this whole
argument down by a polynomial factor so
now really using isolation them out of a
box you can show that once you perturb
the coefficients of the objective
function with high probability you have
a gap of at least inverse polynomial
between the first best and the second
best solutions ok so there's a
non-trivial gap between the first best
and the second best how does that help
us well now we can just sort of in a
lazy way use our assumed pseudo
polynomial time algorithm will only read
as many bits of the VIS as are necessary
so that we're sure we've actually
distinguished the first best from the
second best since there in verse poly
apart you only need a logarithmic number
of bits to do this you feed that into
the pseudo polynomial it's actually
gonna run in polynomial time and we're
done
you don't have issues routing I mean
with rounding them you will read the
amount of bits that you don't know is to
round up or to run down yeah so you do
need a lemma here but there's something
very clever where basically you run the
pseudo polynomial time algorithm not
just sort of like for the V for the
current set of the eyes but also kind of
for the worst case setting of what the
rest of the bits could possibly look
like which again just corresponds to
adding one bit so you really run the
pseudo-polynomial algorithm twice you
know once with the current set of bits
one with kind of the worst thing that
could be for your optimal solution and
you check that you get the same thing if
you get the same thing both times you
run the pseudo polynomial time algorithm
then actually you know guaranteed you've
identified the optimal one so you're
right you need that you need to certify
it but that uses the same ideas the
question other questions
so the last thing I want to say about
smooth analysis is to just highlight
where I think you know there's the
biggest opportunity for really
high-impact work I think the work that
would be really important and this
concerns local search simplex method we
mentioned at the outset there's this
embarrassing gap between the worst-case
running time and the empirical running
time on almost all instances the same
thing is true for local search problems
and to be clear when I talk about local
search I'm not talking about the quality
of the local optimum that you reach it
might suck okay that's not my problem
what I want to focus on is the number of
iterations needed until you reach some
possibly bad local optimum and that you
know basically even though it's almost
impossible to find an instance where a
local search algorithm you know runs
sort of much slower than linear
nevertheless theoretically one can
contrive worst case examples for most
local search algorithms where they do
require an exponential number of steps
to reach a local optimum so again just
like with the simplex method with local
search we have this exact same gap of
exponential worst-case running time with
you know often linear or better running
time in practice so again this would
seem to be right in the wheelhouse of
smooth analysis seems like there should
be great applications here actually
there are so there's already been some
really nice works in this area so for
example you know what I like is on
k-means you know which is one of the
most widely used local search algorithms
and so Arthur of death Levitsky Manthey
and rugland they proved on the one hand
the worst-case running time is
exponential it's actually not that easy
to prove but they proved that and then
also in a smooth sense if you perturb
the points that it's clustering then it
does have smooth polynomial running time
so no you know that that was a little
more technical so I don't want to talk
about it too much but let me talk about
an easy result to give you kind of the
flavor of this topic of smooth analysis
of local search so let me talk about the
Traveling Salesman problem okay so
there's a bunch of different local
search algorithms you can define for the
Traveling Salesman problem I want to
talk about the two opt heuristic so let
me remind you with the two hops your
stick is right so we at any given time
we have it we have a tsb tour we need to
define you know which tours could we
move to in one step what are the
neighboring tours so here's how here's
what you're allowed to do in two opt you
take your current tour you pick any two
edges that you want to
rent or you remove them that shatters
the tour into two different pieces to
kinetic components and then you
reconnect those four vertices in the
unique way that gives you another
connected graph okay so that just moves
you from a tour like this to a tour like
this or vice versa ok that's the two
hottie Ristic choose your favorite pair
of edges and do this swap okay so anglet
rugland invoking and analyze this too
optimistic and actually they work hard
to prove some really good running time
bound smooth running time bounds of the
two hot pure istic I just want to show
you that if we want we're willing to be
sloppy with the polynomial time bound of
really have kind of a bad polynomial
bound we could do this very easily okay
so what's the idea so the idea is
basically to just combine the isolation
lemo with the Union bound all right so
let me let me say more all right so how
what's what's a method by which you
could prove that local search is going
to run quickly well a sufficient
condition would be suppose it makes a
lot of progress at every single time
step and so suppose every improving
local move you ever take you decrease
the distance to the best solution by
some inverse poly factor that means
you're going to stop if nowhere else at
the global optimum within a polynomial
number of time steps so that's exactly
how this is prudent you prove that
actually every single improving local
move you might ever see will with high
probability improve by a lot okay so
that you can only have a polynomial
number of time steps before terminator
so how do you prove that well the
Chiappa that what's special about two
options they're just really aren't that
many different local moves that ever
come up right so yeah you have a lot of
tours and stuff but any move from one
tour to another really just involves a
quartet of vertices so there's really
only n choose for local moves I have a
polynomial number of local moves now if
you just fix one local move and you want
to say this one local move if it's
improving improves by a lot then you
just use the isolation lemma argument
from the last slot it just works out of
the box so for a fixed local move you
know that with high probability it's
going to be big if there's only a pawn
on a number of local moves Union bound
tells you that every single local move
will make a big big big improvement and
so therefore you can't run too long you
run in polynomial time okay
nice to kill ya with an exponential
dependence on k sure there's going to be
right so you're gonna have like a 2k up
here kind of thing yeah I don't yeah I
don't know that I don't know that there
any results known which would be Polly
and K&N i'm not sure if a glittered all
prove that or not like i don't remember
seeing a result that was Polly in both
KNN that'd be nice okay alright so this
same trick of just taking a Union bound
over all possible local moves can be
used in other problems so this is again
this is kind of like the easy case this
is when you know smooth analysis just
kind of immediately gets you what you
want think for example about Max cut and
I have in mind the flip neighborhood
okay so in any iteration you take one
vertex from one of the two sides and you
move it to the other side okay so that's
the local search algorithm we're talking
about if the graph that you're doing
this on has degree bounded degree or
degree up to log in again it's pretty
easy to prove that there's only a
polynomial number of different local
moves that ever come up so again by the
isolation alema and the Union bound you
can just prove that all of them make
healthy progress and therefore you're
just not going to not going to take them
any steps but what about in a general
graph so in a general graph there are an
exponential number of sort of
fundamentally distinct local moves you
might take and we don't know which you
do not know the smooth running time of
local search and max cut with a flip
neighborhood in a general graph we do
know and this is a non-trivial result by
Assad and rogue lane that at least it's
not worse than Kwazii polynomial meaning
end of the log in ok so that's an upper
bound on the smooth complexity of local
search form ax cut we do not know if
it's polynomial or not it's suggestive
that it's polynomial but no one knows a
proof isn't the local move just moving a
verdict from one side to the other you
ever have more than you're saying
because so with respect to a given
configuration so if I fix the current
cut you're absolutely right that there's
only n different moves but then you know
this cuts going to be changing you have
an exponential number of different cuts
his whole history yeah and then that's
what you need for this Union bound
you'll have to say everything that ever
happens I don't want to understand I
just want to know any local move you
ever take is going to have healthy
progress yeah good are the questions we
get next good yes you're right I should
have said that its way to Mexico say
like you know real numbers between zero
and one yeah in fact I mean this is even
open just in the average case analysis
world I think where you have a uniform
01 number attached to each edge I think
even that is not known yeah no no no so
so I'm sorry if I gave that impression
so I focused on the easy ones just
because it's a you know it's a tutorial
so 4k means you have to work a lot
harder and still on some level you're
taking some kind of Union been at the
end of the day we have to be very clever
about sort of equivalence classes of
different moves and then you take the
Union bound over a polynomial number of
equivalence classes and you know here
again there is you know sort of a union
down but they somehow have to again say
you know kind of have these equivalence
classes of sequences that might come up
to Union bound over so it's not it mean
it's none is it quite non-trivial to get
quasi polynomial to get sub exponential
that requires work as far as we
understand
alright so there's an obvious open
question specific case of Mexico with a
flip neighborhood is a polymer or not I
would definitely like to know the answer
to that you know actually I wonder if
something like much more sweeping is
true right so if you think about that
buyer walking result that said whenever
you're solvable in pseudo polynomial
time then you're also solvable in
polynomial in smooth polynomial time
local search problems they're all
solvable in pseudo polynomial time this
sort of what sesh was alluding to right
so say you have integer objective
function coefficients every single step
you take is going to improve by an
integer value so if you have poly
bounded coefficients it's only going to
run for a polynomial number of
iterations so the hypothesis in the
buyer blocking result actually holds for
every local search problem pretty much
but this is about sort of finding a
local optimum not about finding a global
optimum and so we don't know if this is
true but I could imagine I could imagine
that for pretty much any binary
optimization problem and any way of
defining the neighborhood structure so
that you have polynomial diameter
between any two feasible solutions for
all I know every single problem of that
form has smooth polynomial complexity I
could imagine that being true and has it
been driving crazy for years I have to
say so if you have ideas I'd love to
hear them again the issue is sort of
avoiding the Union bound rights the
native union bounds not going to prove
this in general you have an exponential
number of fundamentally distinct local
moves you have an exponential number of
local Optima it's kind of hard to figure
out how to handle them
yes no to look welcome yeah
okay and then should say that even in
the simplex method which maybe you think
of as being resolved for 15 years
there's actually some really important
open questions that would make that
theory kind of more immediately
meaningful to kind of what we see in
practice so for example we know nothing
about non-gaussian perturbations we know
nothing about the most popular choices
of the pivot rule we only know it for
the shadow pivot rule which is kind of
you know the easiest one to prove things
about and then another important one
would be sparsity preserving
perturbations so remember when when we
talked about the spill and 10 model we
talked about how you add a Gaussian a
small Gaussian to every entry of the
constraint matrix every entry of the
right hand side lots of the linear
programs we care about have sparse
constraint matrices and the algorithms
that solve them really leverage that
sparsity to do well so could you get
away with only adding a small Gaussian
to the nonzero entries of a constraint
matrix that would be really a quite
major resort if someone could prove that
okay so questions that's the smooth
analysis section two more topics but
both are pretty short okay now this is a
sparse question in these maximization
problems what if just you didn't add
Gaussian noise to every proficient VI
but to some random subset did you know
anything so about large enough random
subset you know anything they ever I'm
trying to think if the proof gives you
something I think you'd have to talk
about the I don't know that you could
have something generic for every binary
optimization problem without perturbing
everything but for specific binary
optimization problems I think you could
get away with a weaker assumption yeah I
haven't seen any results on that so it's
a good question I guess it's not the
only few
little thing because then zeros who
remain zeros that's right that's right I
think there's some I feel like there's
some partial results then I saw once but
but it's basically open yeah
the agonies of progress by their
distribution and integral although they
are or can be hard or their animal toy
problems but a properly self for power
can you create cricketer the heck of
fine going capacity is illusion don't
see what you are using a distribution
are you are you asking about average
case hardness or for example is next
year well described below oh the magic
marker for operation guys based on some
children but how about the Opera itself
although each how this package power
property hips on spin hospice the bigger
suitcase fusion that can be easier to
solve but how do you compare to properly
with different distributions yeah I mean
so I think you're touching on sort of a
really important issue that
unfortunately we have not that much
theory about so Luca Trevis on here at
Berkeley is one of the experts on this
so an average case complexity like we
just don't have a you know we don't have
a lot of reductions between different
problems distribution pairs to other
ones so that's what that's been a wide
open question in complexity theory
forever basically and people you know
there's been some nice progress and I
think we should keep working on it but
that hardness average case hardness
theory is not mature enough to connect
to many of the things I'm talking about
today I think someday it will be but
we're a long ways from that
okay all right so I want to say a little
bit about other types of what I call
hybrid models and so what I mean by a
hybrid model is some kind of
interpolation between worst case and
average case analysis and the thesis
which have given you examples for I'll
give you more examples is that for lots
of problems where worst case analysis
fails the right thing to do is sort of a
robust version of average case analysis
one of these hybrid models so what do I
mean by this I just mean that for so so
an average case analysis I tell you one
distribution and you optimize for that
one distribution in a hybrid model I
give you a set of distributions I say
look I promise you I'm going to pick one
of these distributions and draw an input
randomly from it but you don't know
which distribution it's going to be okay
and you want to have an algorithm which
does well simultaneously for any
distribution that I might choose it for
every distribution that you might
encounter that's what I mean by a hybrid
model so worst case over the choice of
the distribution average case with
respect to that worst-case distribution
okay let me point out that the last two
topics are special cases of these hybrid
models I just so to tell you how is a
hybrid model I just have to tell you the
distributions so think about like
planted click for example right so we
have this initial input distribution
which is just nature the area training
graph of the planet cleek and then we
have this monotone adversary and the
monitory adversary just maps each
possible output of nature to another
graph so if you combine a monotone
adversary with nature you get an induced
distribution over graphs as you vary
over all monotone adversary as you vary
over all distributions you have to
handle in the semi-random planet click
model so there we are exactly asking for
an algorithm which does well I use
correct simultaneously with respect to
any instance in this class similarly in
smooth analysis now you have one
distribution for each point that the
adversary might choose so for each input
and for that input you then look at the
perturbation around that input you want
an algorithm that does simultaneously
well for every one of you sort of
perturbed point masses legend some other
examples which we either have seen
earlier in the week or we'll see
tomorrow so Matt talked a lot about
secretary problems more generally you
know random order problems so you know
the secretary problem and adversary if
you like thinks of n different numbers
whatever it wants
but the nature comes in and presents
them to the algorithm in random order
okay so again you kind of want to
algorithm which does well no matter what
the adversary does for a random ordering
that's again a hybrid model in Adam in
the keels talk on Tuesday we saw some
statements of the form you know that
some you know natural algorithm prior
free algorithm is simultaneously
competitive for any mg1 system and the
point here is that you know this G this
is the service time distribution they
were getting competitive guarantees no
matter what G is so that's again a
family of distributions as you range
over possible g's and a single algorithm
that's competitive with optimal for all
of them and then Anna I hope you go to
her talk tomorrow morning one of the
things she'll talk about is prior
independent auction so this is part of
algorithmic game theory where again you
you don't assume that you know with
distribution like you historically do in
economics you just assume something like
independence of different bidders and
you want an auction which does almost as
well as optimal no matter what the
distribution actually is let me just
mention again you know like I said the
the paging literature you know premio
sort of anticipates much of what's been
going on this century and so they also
had notions of different hybrid models
this is the paper I mentioned at the
beginning kutsu PSN pop dimitru called
beyond competitive analysis that gave
rise to the title of this tutorial if
you went to ellie's nice talk yesterday
morning about learning you might be
wondering about that that may seem to
use sort of like the og hybrid model
right so back in the back in the 70s and
80s how is it a hybrid model or again
there's an unknown distribution okay i
promise i'll give you iid samples right
so you know you know something about the
samples you know their ID but you don't
know the distribution that their ID from
and you want a single learning algorithm
which works well simultaneously whatever
the unknown distribution is works well
in that context means low classification
error so you classify things almost as
well as the target concept or the best
concept in your in your class so this
you know but this is this is
historically about classification you
know this pack learning model and so you
might wonder you know we've seen all
these hybrid models that are about sort
of designing algorithms choosing
algorithms you know is there some way to
you know get the pack learning sort of
you know philosophy in the same room is
the algorithm design philosophy and so I
want to briefly just sort of point out
that there's been a lot of work along
these
lines just very recently this is kind of
a you know which I'm very excited about
so the first example of sort of taking a
learning theoretical algorithm design
with worst-case Garrett with sort of
performance guarantees is the literature
on self-improving algorithms so this was
initially done for sorting by alone at
all and then there's been some nice
follow-up work by Clarkson seshadri and
others on low dimensional convex
geometry so let me explain to you what
they were doing so the pack formalism is
pretty implicit in this literature but
let me explain to you what they're doing
when they do self-improving sorting
algorithms and I think the analogy will
be clear so they had in mind you know
arrays so input arrays of length n
coming from some distribution and the
only assumption they made was that
different array entries were independent
didn't have to be identically
distributed but they needed them to be
independently distributed so you're
getting these arrays of length n drawn
from this unknown distribution and you
want to with you know ideally as few
number of training examples as possible
figure out a sorting algorithm which is
almost as good as the information
theoretic optimal sorting algorithm for
this unknown distribution because you
want to minimize the expected number of
comparisons with respect to this unknown
distribution and they show that this can
be done so they show with a relatively
small number of samples you know it's
some suitable data structures you really
can have algorithms which are
simultaneously competitive with the
optimum for any product distribution
over array entries so that's
self-improving algorithms a lot of nice
stuff there another thing which I think
Anna will probably talk about tomorrow
is the idea of sort of taking the pack
mindset and applying it to auction
designs is it going to part of Albert in
the game theory so in economics you know
forever the dominant paradigm has been
what we would call average case analysis
they would call it Bayesian analysis
right so there's like this common prior
assumption and most economic work and
then you optimize with respect to the
prior so that's the sense in which is
average case analysis you know but if
you want to try to apply that theory for
example to you know figure out how to
set reserve prices in a sponsored search
option or whatever there's always this
question which is like what is this
common prior where do i get this
distribution from but of course for
computer science is the answer is sort
of obvious right it should be from data
from the past and boy does that sound
like a learning problem you know you're
giving samples of bids for
options in the past you want to use that
to get an auction which is almost
optimal with respect to an unknown
distribution and indeed just you know
recently you know there's been
developing lots of you know strong and
useful connections between auction
theory on the one hand and statistical
learning theory on the other hand and
finally let me just mention this will be
the topic of the open lecture that I'm
giving in October and this is also you
know sort of directly inspired by some
of the work you'll hear from Kevin in
the afternoon so the idea you know in
practice you know what if you don't want
to design an algorithm from scratch what
if rather you have an algorithm
portfolio so a bunch of algorithms for
the same problem with widely varying
performance and you want to figure out
which one to use what's the best
algorithm for your particular set of
instances or maybe you want to kind of
even take it to the next level and
actually you know based on course
features of an instance on the fly
select which algorithm from your
portfolio you want to run on it okay so
X at would be one example where this
works works great and so for years have
been sort of inspired by kevins results
and I wondered you know what would a
theory look like the kind of mirrors
what he's doing and this has been the
best I've been able to come up with so
far so I'll talk about that more in
October one of you one more thing again
short so this is meant to tie together
the two parts of the tutorial ok so both
tutorials have been about you know what
are models of data you know that sort of
Dean some inputs more relevant than
others the difference was in part one we
were looking at the terminus two
conditions like these stability notions
for clustering the r.i.p condition for
compressed sensing in part two we've
been looking at all probabilistic models
a semi-random models smooth analysis and
other hybrid models so the last point I
want to make is that actually you know
these two worlds have a fruitful
connection between the two specifically
you can think about the probabilistic
models we've been talking about in part
two and use them to generate in a
basically almost automatic way novel
deterministic conditions okay for a
result of the type we were saying in
part one I know that sounds a little big
so let me do i'm just going to do two
examples revisiting things you've
already seen and interpreting them in a
different way and then i'm just going to
mention to new things which apply these
same paradigm to problems you haven't
seen okay so the first thing that I just
want to revisit was
r l 1 minimization recover result in the
compressive sensing setting so remember
this here we had an underdetermined
linear system and we wanted to use a
linear program to get back an unknown
spar signal and you know one way you can
think about what we did so remember we
knew we needed we knew we needed
conditions on a because it's an np-hard
problem in general one way to think
about what we did here is well imagine
we first did just sort of an average
case thought experiment we said well
what have the constraint matrix was
random I'm not saying it's random but
just for fun you know Randall as that
you know as the analyst imagine it was
random say like gaussians then you can
imagine proving that with high
probability l1 minimization works and
then from your proof you can then back
out what it was about a random matrix
you actually need it to get the recovery
guarantee so that's one way you could
kind of motivate like where an our IP
condition comes from you say what is
really the property of a random matrix
which drives this result okay so you do
an average case thought experiment with
random matrix but then from it you
extract a deterministic condition a
German istic restriction on the input
which which has the guarantee and this
of course is stronger all right so if
you pick a random matrix it'll satisfy
this with high probability but there'll
be other totally non random matrices
which also satisfy this condition like
say the Fourier matrix and then you also
get polynomial time recovery so it's
always sort of better to have a
deterministic surrogate if you can get
away with it so that's the first example
I wanted to revisit the second example
is one you saw Niccolo talked about at
length and width great eloquence
yesterday the idea of online learning
okay and minimizing regret so let me
remind you the setting from yesterday so
there's some action set maybe you want
to buy or sell a stock and you have some
time horizon of capital T days and it's
this very unfair feeling game where you
or your algorithm has to first commit to
an action or distribution over actions
if you like and then the adversary gets
to go second sort of give you whatever
reward vector at once ok which sounds
very unfair and it is in a way and so
it's easier to prove is that there's you
know if you try to apply competitive
analysis in the most straight for
way it's again one of these epic fails
okay it says all algorithms are equally
terrible gives you know it doesn't lead
you to design anything interesting so
the obvious way to do competitive
analysis would be that can try to
compete with the best action sequence in
hindsight okay if you could go back in
time and choose the best action every
possible day how much better would you
have done okay compared to this
benchmark every algorithm is terrible
but but it is kind of amazing if you
change the benchmark if you say I don't
want to compete with the best action
sequence in hindsight I just want to
compete with the best fixed action in
hindsight everything changes okay all of
a sudden we have this you know really
beautiful and deep theory basically just
because we change the benchmark with the
obvious benchmark there were no
interesting algorithms with this
benchmark were naturally led to really
cool algorithms like you saw yesterday
hedge multiplet of weights whatever you
want to call it so somehow getting the
benchmark right was fundamental to
getting sort of this theory off of the
ground so that's cool but there's sort
of this question this with a two-fold
question so first of all still what
exactly does it mean so it's cool we can
do it but what does it mean to compete
with the best fixed action in hindsight
when our algorithm is not actually using
a fixed action it's what seems kind of
apples and oranges how to interpret that
but maybe more importantly like suppose
you wanted to find the right benchmark
and some other problem how could you
what lesson could you 'extract from no
regard online learning that might
generalize to some other domain you
might want to think about so let me
again propose a sort of average case
thought experiment it's again it's just
a reinterpretation of this well-known
stuff so imagine i told you that there's
some distribution Dion reward vectors
and every day the reward vector is going
to be chosen iid from this distribution
D so this is a trivial problem for
online learning right so what do you do
on day one we're going to say well which
action has the best reward the highest
expected reward I'm gonna play that what
are you doing d2 well the same thing
because it's again another Heidi draw
from the same distribution so if you
knew that if you knew a distribution and
you knew that reward vectors were being
drawn from them
you would just play the same optimal
action every single time step you would
use a fixed action if you knew that it
was I ID from a distribution d suppose
you didn't know d but you knew the
reward vectors were iid well you don't
know d so you don't know the best fixed
action but you know there's some fixed
action which is optimal so what would be
an interpretation of doing the best
fixed action in hindsight well it's
certainly an only stronger statement
then saying you're competing with the
actual optimum right so the real best
action sequence in hindsight for every
unknown distribution d under the
assumption that the road vectors are iid
okay and if you think about it actually
from this thought experiment you can
just generate this benchmark of the best
fixed action and hindsight you can go to
the average case thought experiment say
as I range over all unknown
distributions d what are all of the
different optimal strategies that arise
well that's just all of the optimal
fixed actions and this now induces a
deterministic criterion a deterministic
benchmark the best fixed action in
hindsight it's the best optimal strategy
that it might have been had it been an
ID distribution now just in the
compressed sense of world and compressed
sensing world it's better to have the
worst case guarantees than to have this
right so in the worst case guarantees
you're going to get no regret even when
the reward vectors are adversarial and
not stochastic so you get a meaningful
guarantee more generally but in
particular it holds in this case and
again sort of the takeaway point is that
this thought experiment naturally leads
you to discover that best fixed action
benchmark another kind of folklore
example you might want to think about
would be when you talk about say static
optimality for search trees that's
really just saying you're competing with
the best search tree on any sequence of
iid accesses exactly the same kind of
thing all right so last slide I told you
I would revisited two things chemistry
nevertheless context in which sure yep
that's a good example and there you're
actually just yeah there you just
optimal basically yeah yep distribution
that you've had before does it matter if
they're heavy build upper like tail are
you making some assumptions about them
when you're looking at the range of all
distribution good question depends on
the problem I mean generally I mean so
when you're doing these hybrid models
but so figuring you know deciding on a
hybrid model amounts to deciding on a
class of distributions and you basically
can never get away with all
distributions because that would include
all possible point masses which would
get you back to worst-case analysis so
you need to sort of assume you'd assume
something so like in the self-improving
algorithms work that I mentioned they
assumed independence between the array
entries so they didn't assume their
identity distributed but they need it to
be a product distribution in the
algorithmic game theory results usually
again you need to assume a product
distribution and and then in that
context if you have you know you neither
need some kind of bound on the range of
values or you need some control on the
Taylor distributions so the right way to
define those distributions is going to
be problem specific but you know I just
think this is a good mindset to have
okay to last slide so the two things I
just revisited accomplished two
different things both had in common that
we thought about the average case world
not because we were literally going to
analyze the average case world but more
because we were confused about you know
what should be what should we be
studying in the deterministic world in
the compressed sensing case we did the
average case thought experiment not to
suggest a benchmark that's not we were
doing but to suggest the deterministic
condition on inputs basically they have
a novel way to identify a special case
of an np-hard problem that's what it
accomplished in compressed sensing what
it accomplished an online learning was
it generated this benchmark okay it gave
us this best fixed action in hindsight
instead of the perhaps more obvious best
fixed action sequence in hindsight so
these things have these does this
paradigm have other uses it does so one
thing which i'm not i'm not sure whether
or not Anna will talk about tomorrow but
another part of album the game theory
where the whole point in getting the
theory up and running was to find the
right benchmarks was prior free auction
design so this was pioneered by Goldberg
hartline Carlin sax and rights
their motivation was having a worst-case
analog of the traditional economic
theory which is average case analysis of
auctions and again just like with online
learning if you take the obvious
approach of a competitive analysis it
tells you all options suck and they all
suck equally so you just get nothing you
do not have an interesting theory but
Goldberg at all proposed benchmarks you
know analogous to the best fixed action
in hindsight such that it does naturally
guide you to designing really
interesting auctions with worst-case
guarantees for that benchmark and then I
work with Jason heartline we use the
same kind of average case thought
experiment to generalize and sort of
maybe make more automatic this this goal
of generating of proposing relevant
revenue benchmarks so basically you do
an average case thought experiment you
say well assume that bidders are
actually subsumed bidders actually are
coming from a distribution I don't know
what the distribution is but I'll at
least assume that they're independent
what are all of the different optimal
things I might want to do ranging over
all distributions for iit bidders and
then i want to compete with the best of
all of those optimal things i might want
to do in the ID case exactly analogous
and no regret online learning where the
fick the best fixed action can be
interpreted as the range of all the best
things you might want to do in the ID
case same thing works here so back to
defining deterministic conditions so
I'll analogous to compressive sensing
this is what i'll talk about in the
workshop in September which is applying
that sort of philosophy to social
networks typically in the study of
social and information networks people
study them with generative models but
you might have heard of like
preferential attachment with a chun chun
lu model these kinds of things and so
the question is ok can you take a hybrid
model approach can you say well would it
be cool to have an algorithm which
worked kind of no matter which
generative model you believed in so here
the class of distributions are going to
be all positive generative models for
social networks and we use that
distribution in the slot experiments to
get deterministic conditions on graphs
so if you like just graph classes we
identify graph classes meant to capture
all plausible social networks so we
focus on properties related to try out a
closure ok so that's how you do this
here there's also been some follow-up
work
including here at Berkeley okay so that
rats up what i want to say I'll leave
the part 2 summary up on the slide and
happy to take more questions thanks a
lot